[Music]
this week on
forward just about every aspect of
Congress as an entity is uh either
inadequate in some degree or out of date
drives me crazy that you have these
folks on Capitol Hill who Proclaim that
they're miserable yell at the
institution they're within but then
frequently won't lift a finger to make
the changes that they can make there is
so much to be done because government is
so much bigger than it was 50 or 100
years ago and instead of prioritizing
things that are important and
substantive it was so much symbolic
stuff being put into the uh legislative
[Music]
process it's my pleasure to Welcome to
the podcast political scientist senior
fellow at AEI which is a think tank and
author of the prei book Congress
overwhelmed the decline in Congressional
capacity and prospects for reform Kevin
Kosar welcome Kevin thank you for having
me on no problem I'm excited to talk to
you because you are one of the
preeminent thinkers on what the heck is
going on or not going on in terms of our
institutions first can you give people a
bit of your background you have a
doctorate in political science from NYU
yeah I went to NYU and got my Master's
and PhD there wrote a dissertation on
how uh Congress had historically uh
handled K through 12 education policy
and then after that I thought it was
going to be an academic but I ended up
um taking what I thought would be a
2-year gig at the Congressional research
service the core of Nerds inside the
Library of Congress uh and that turned
into 11 years and then after that
wonderful experience I hopped to um the
private Think Tank world where I've been
the last nine years wow you've been a
think tanker for
nine years yeah and and CRS was like the
government version of it um we literally
just a core of nerds trying to give the
facts and Analysis and and feed Congress
the information it needs fantastic so um
so clearly you were shaped by that
experience and you came with this book a
few years ago that that I I named
Congress overwhelmed uh so can you
describe your experience both in core uh
and then uh the think tank World by the
way I I admire your research a great
deal I agree with most all of it U which
we'll dig into but U but yeah like what
was the experience like well it was uh
it was incredible um being at
CRS was an opportunity to kind of see
the legislature both Chambers uh close
up but I didn't have to sign up for
either the Republicans or the Democrats
teams I can maintain my distance and I
work with staff on both sides I work
with members on both sides plenty of
committees both Chambers and it was an a
lengthy education and seeing how the
wheels turn and uh you know it's a civil
servant position basically tenured for
life and after about a decade of it I um
I was sufficiently concerned about what
I was seeing going on in Congress that I
was thinking I I I I need to figure out
a way to try to do something wow and
then this opportunity came along where I
could step out to a think tank and I
would be kind of free
to write research and speak very clearly
about the institution itself and um so
so that's what I did well congrats on
that uh and I I think the country may be
better off for you deciding to come out
to the outside and say hey guys uh
things aren't working so well so why
aren't things so working working so well
I mean the average American senses that
things are getting Rocky um now they
they they may attribute it to one thing
or another but you've been at this for
years and years what's been going on oh
boy where where to start uh I so I hope
at some point we'll talk about we'll
talk about primaries since elections are
the way we
hire yeah totally but uh gosh I mean
you're typical commentators political
scientists people who look closely at
Congress they they tend to couch what's
wrong uh with it under what I call the
3ps either they say it's the people it's
the parties or it's polarization those
are the kind of units of analysis when
they try to explain what's what's going
on and every one of those explanations
um get part of the picture
correct uh what I and Lee drutman of new
America and Tim laira of of James
Madison University and the various
contributors to our volume said was
those things are all important but let's
look at the institution tion itself
Congress is an organization it's an
entity it's a firm whatever you want to
call
it is it structured in a way that gives
it a good chance of succeeding at what's
expected of it and when you use that
kind of framework it's Illuminating and
also rather depressing I thought you
were going to lead us to a fourth p uh
which is primaries which we can talk
about um but but let's first talk about
what your diagnosis is so Congress is
not set up as an institution to succeed
and I'm I'm going to throw a few things
out there that I that I when I found out
I was like whoa that's messed up um so
there there's been a rule in place for a
number of years now I think it's uh
called the htert rule where you can't
bring legislation to the floor unless
it's supported by a majority of the
majority wi which means that if you're
in the minority party you're doing very
very little
legislating because you can't actually
bring anything so someone in Congress
said to me that if you're in the
minority party and you don't have a
committee gavel in your hand or you
don't have a senior appointment in one
of these uh the these bodies that that
uh deliberates over laws which is a
minority of members you might as well be
a piece of furniture um now of course
most members of Congress aren't going to
be like yeah I just kind of hang out and
you know don't do anything um but if
you're in the minority party that
unfortunately is is what it resembles
sure yeah ABS absolutely uh the sort of
collegiality um
between partisans to you know work with
one another uh particularly on high
salience issue it's just it's almost
non-existent um take any big issue like
immigration you you just are not going
to see Democrats and Republicans talking
with each other uh and working together
on Solutions um they just don't feel
incentivized to do that I mean the good
news is that on like really boring low
salience issues they've got the space to
do it um but funny enough your question
leads us to the primaries
issue think about it immigration if
you're the Democratic party do you
really want to solve that problem if
you're the Republican Party do you
really want to solve that problem no
you've got pretty strong incentives to
not solve it but rather to campaign upon
it to fund raise upon it and therefore
you own the issue but you don't own the
solution and that's particularly the
case when you're running through the
primaries where you have people who are
either really hard on the left or really
hard on the right who are more than
likely to vote in those primaries and so
yeah that's part that's part of the
problem the H rule kind of is a
reflection of the incentive structure um
that's currently in place so you were
concerned about some of these things it
sounds like 10 years ago was there a
degradation or a trend line so one of
the trend lines I've seen is that folks
who would be described as moderate uh
have been declining in number in part
because of the nature of the parties and
the polarization and the primaries H the
pe's in there um but but you said you
were concerned back then um what was
driving your concerns and I mean it's
gotten worse since then well it was um
in part what the chambers were spending
time
on um you know frequently I would see
the House of Representatives trying to
push through bills that had no chance of
making it to the Senate to say nothing
of getting a signature from a president
but they were pouring time into it and
it's like well this is not policymaking
this is symbolic Behavior that's a
that's a concern of mine I was also
concerned with the sheer workload there
is so much to be done because government
is so much bigger than it was 50 or 100
years ago and instead of prioritizing
things that are important and
substantive there was just so much
symbolic stuff being put into the uh
legislative process I was like oh okay
that's that's troubling too I saw the
kind
of Bizarro Behavior which turned out was
totally rational going on in hearings
where members were not actually
interested in learning from a witness
and then going back and trying to think
about how they could improve a policy or
develop a new policy but instead we're
just either erating the person uh or
singing their praises um without taking
any substance away from it and like I
kept wondering what's going on is it the
people are these people are just
goofballs in Congress and then I
realized no they're they're rationally
responding to the incentive structure
and that's where I kind of said
uhoh because it if the incentives don't
change they're not going to change and
governance isn't going to get better and
so that was a real alarm Bell for
me this podcast is sponsored by
expressvpn going online without
expressvpn is like changing while
leaving your window wide open gross you
might not have anything to hide but why
give random creeps a chance to invade
your privacy that's why I use expressvpn
it's super easy you hit a button and
then you just beam in best of all you
know no one can see what you're doing no
big tech companies no ad companies no
other companies why use expressvpn when
you go online it is just you and your
surfing no one can see it you know it's
the way to go because a bunch of big
companies say hey all of you high-end
consultants and spies use
expressvpn secure your online activity
by visiting expressvpn.com slang today
today that's
expressvpn.com yangang and you can get
an extra 3 months free expressvpn.com
gang you you talk about these
organizational capacities how
government's gotten much bigger and more
complex how policy by the way I mean I I
agree with you that if you look at
Congressional staffers uh so a member of
Congress shows up and they have a
handful of staffers uh they do have a
policy person typically but then the
policy person has to get up to speed on
everything under the sun and you know
where they turn to for information
industry which is lobbyist be like hey
what the heck's going on with Telecom
and it's like oh I'll tell you what's
going on with
Telecom they what's going on with AI
what's going on with anything under the
sun um and so they're very industry
dependent so you you have a real uh
handin glove relationship there and in
terms of policy by the way it's
exacerbated by the fact that uh I
believe the number something like 60 65%
of uh members after they leave just
become lobbyists so it's literally like
your old colleague coming and being like
hey what's up you know what you should
really look at is this bill and then
their compensation um uh goes up so
that's one element of capacity that I
think most people looking at it
objectively would be like huh like you
don't have a whole lot of indep
dependent um political or sorry
independent policy guidance uh and you
don't have the expertise uh necessarily
to get up to speed on on on everything
so that's one thing that comes to mind
for me what are the other organizational
gaps gez just about every
aspect of Congress as an entity is uh
either inadequate in some degree or out
ofd take their technology a common
complaint amongst members of Congress is
that they get a PDF of a bill sent to
them and they're encouraged to you know
read it and hopefully sign off on it
well where are the track changes why am
I looking at this document and it's
referencing things like 39 us code
section 1 a
B3 but there's no explanation of what
that is how am I supposed to assess this
apparently I have to go online and look
up that piece of the current law and try
to figure this out like the whole you
know the track changes things like that
little popup hyperlinks bubbles things
that would explain what a provision
might mean that's not there they're not
working in the cloud they're still
shoveling paper to each other and
emailing PDFs you know members of
Congress until recently when they
started their jobs they were handed
pagers beepers you know like from that
Seinfield episode 30 years years ago why
were they given those because that's how
they would be notified when there was a
vote called and that they needed to show
up and vote why wasn't there an app they
just hadn't developed it like and that's
just a technology slight processes look
at our budget process 50 years old
Congress is not following it it doesn't
incentivize budget sensible budgeting
behavior and actually incentivizes bad
behavior that's an example of a process
that's lousy hearings you know they've
devolved but it's still the same format
for the most part you bunch of guys and
ladies in suits up on a dis looking down
at Witnesses you get three minutes to
give a
statement then you get questions and
then they gavel it and leave like is
that the best way to learn to study an
issue no people Congress has fewer staff
than it did 40 years
ago yet it's got way more work to do
like that's a problem too it it's got
fewer people you mean fewer staff per
office because the the number of of
members obviously is constant and that
something maybe we should discuss like
the number should be much greater right
oh yeah we're the average member of the
House of Representatives has
760,000 constituents you know the number
of Americans keeps going up and up but
for the last 100 years the number of
Representatives has been basically
Frozen yeah I I remember reading
something like that that when it started
out they maybe represented 80 to 100,000
people each on average which if you
thought thought about it it's like that
might be doable that's like a very very
large college town you might actually be
able to have a sense of what's going on
but then if you uh multiply that times
eight uh it becomes impossible obviously
yeah and I would say the you know the
other thing and this is something I know
you've thought much about and spoken out
about is uh Congress is nonpartisan
nerds you know like you said member of
Congress they they get hit with a
difficult issue the first thing they
want to do is like oh I'll just turn to
somebody in Private Industry or perhaps
that person in Private Industry or a
representative from K Street shows up in
their office before they even ask um
whether it's banking or some other issue
Congress has fewer nonpartisan nerds
working at the Congressional research
service and the other legislative branch
support agencies than it did 40 years
ago and in the early 90s you know they
got rid of the office of Technology
assessment right before the internet was
about to bloom they just threw those 120
Smarties away yeah yeah that that that
that was super painful we've been living
with the repercussions ever since well
okay so that's a relatively reasonable
description of what's been going on um
and then this is even before the
unprecedented events of the last number
of weeks
where uh you had speaker McCarthy get Ed
and then a bunch of of failed speaker uh
nominations
and then eventually a new Speaker gets
installed uh now we're not sure how much
this new speaker is going to be able to
get done there are a lot of important
pieces of business uh uh on tap how did
you perceive and receive uh McCarthy's
outing I I personally at the time I went
on CNN and said look guys I may not like
Kevin McCarthy but I prefer having a
functional government to a
non-functioning government
so you know and that that that anyone
who says they know what comes next is
lying cuz no one knows so maybe we could
have made something work in terms of a
deal like instead of having all the
Democrats vote against mat Gates then
some Democrats yelled at me about how
how how McCarthy bad and then I was
thinking like well can you guarantee
that his replacement is going to be
better I mean certainly you can't
guarantee that with a straight face
absolutely absolutely yeah no it was uh
it was distressing to see on a couple of
counts I mean you know for one one there
had been a sort of Norm over the last 15
years or so where the speaker and the
minority leader kind of had an agreement
that if there was ever any if there was
an effort to remove a speaker by his or
her own party the other party would kind
of stay out of it right uh Nancy Pelosi
had a deal like that but we saw that
Norm breakdown we saw eight Republicans
vote against McCarthy all the rest
supported him but all the Dems decideed
to show up and vote they didn't have to
vote they could have just not shown up
they could they just voted president and
just been like hey guys you know and
then you fall short that's what I was
saying it's like just like you know you
can bail him out without bailing him out
if you feel like it but I don't blame
Hakeem Jeff for doing that I I
understand that you know this is the new
world of really brutal partisan Hardball
on high salience issues I mean just look
at how House Republicans behaved on
January 6 like trying to desertify or
say that you know these electoral slates
coming from the states were not you know
real or they were inaccurate and we
should send them back and not count them
so it was disappointing on that count
but like you said it was also
disappointing because there was no plan
on how to replace Mr
McCarthy like if you had a good White
Knight candidate behind him that
everyone would rally behind that have
been great but instead you know Gates
being the kind of publicity performance
hound and personal axe grinder kind of
guy he is he just went in and decided to
to blow things
up hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops probably
on Mondays but hit that Bell and thank
you yeah so so we'll we'll see whether
uh 3 weeks of chaos have led to anything
better and more stable uh I'm I'm
personally a proponent of uh Aid to
various International allies and so it's
it's been upsetting that that has gotten
sidetracked or delayed or maybe even
prevented um we shall see so so you've
been trying to make a case uh in the
think tank world for the last nine years
I'm I'm a Solutions guy uh I'm a big fan
so what are the major things that you've
been pushing for on the outside world uh
in your book and otherwise you're like
look guys I came from the Batts of
Congress I was a nonpartisan nerd I know
how stuff works there and doesn't work
and here's what we should do yeah well
certainly I would start with uh Staffing
Staffing up on the nonpartisan nerds
having those as a resource and as a
counterbalance against the kind of
private sector moneyed interest
pressures uh that get in congress's
ears um that's that's the first thing
you have you have to do
uh the second thing you have to do is to
start drawing on some of the insights
gained by the select committee on the
modernization of Congress about how to
run committees in ways that are just
less toxic for all
involved um you know one of the things
that the Select Committee of the
modernization Congress figured out that
you put people at a round table and you
seat them kind of Dem Republican Dem
Republican instead of splitting it up
into two sides and you have the
witnesses interspersed there you can
have real
conversations and sometimes if you want
to be really clever you don't have to
call it a hearing you can have it be a
round table which means you don't have
to have the cameras there so the
incentive to act up in front of the
cameras and use that as a vehicle for
fundraising or partisan Point scoring
those incentives go away and you can
have Frank conversations where people
are able to say like I don't know you're
a Republican and you got something
interesting to say to me as a Democrat
on this issue I think we might have
grounds to get together on that when a
camera is pres you can't do that so that
would be certainly one way and budget
process our nation's finances are a
wreck that law has to be Rewritten
souped To Nuts to fix the situation how
many members or insiders of Congress are
on the same page we like yeah this
sucks because I I got to say like there
have to be
some you know that's you are absolutely
right that's that was one of the things
that really fueled me to take the leap
from a tenur job for life at the
Congressional research service to a
non-tenured position in a think tank it
was everybody on Capitol Hill with the
exception of a
few outrageous characters is miserable
they're not having fun they came here to
do stuff and they're finding themselves
just swallowed up in Byzantine goofiness
that's not satisfying and I kept
wondering like look you
people per the Constitution have all the
power to change why don't you and it
seemed to be a kind of collective action
problem a learned helplessness where
people just kind of looked around and
Shrugged like yeah that's the way this
place is and I started trying to say
like look it hasn't always been like
this and it doesn't have to be this way
you can reorganize you can fund yourself
as much as you want just be the change
so let let's talk about the mechanics of
this a little bit um the Constitution is
silent in how Congress runs it's
essentially this self-generated rule
book uh so is it the case that any
Majority Leader could be like all right
guys here's a deal we're going to get
ourselves some more nerds we're going to
change our seating assignment we're
going to not have TV cameras and
everything we're not going to call in a
hearing we're going to spend money on
Tech for ourselves we're we're going to
do all sorts of stuff to to modernize
like is that all it would take yeah and
the best part is you don't even need the
leader of the the chamber to do a lot of
that stuff um you know how much money
does the legislative branch get and kind
of does it have a new otaa get created
or an office of you know regulatory
review in the legislative branch the
people on the legislative branch
Appropriations uh subcommittees they
just write that in a law pass it through
the chamber but a bing bada boom
committee chairman they don't have to
hold hearings in the oldfashioned way
they can do whatever they want they're W
man this this is like a physician heal
thyself thing what a magical Vision you
have I mean it' be great for the country
drives me crazy that you have these
folks on Capitol Hill who Proclaim that
they're miserable yell at the
institution there within but then
frequently won't lift a finger to make
the changes that they can make like
that's not okay be the
change
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
it's a pretty short list of things you
can do that are going to make you
happier healthier more energetic more
productive every single day you know
what's on that list getting the right
freaking mattress and what's the right
mattress for you if you go to Helix
sleep you take their personalized sleep
quiz and they will send you one of 20
unique mattresses made for you and you
alone well not you and you alone like 5%
of people do the math for 100 night free
trial you can sleep on this thing for 3
months it will keep you cool don't just
take my word for it my kids seek out
this mattress in the house it's the
number one rated mattress picked by GQ
and Wired Magazine this mattress will
actually make you happier healthier and
more productive Helix is offering 20%
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com yangang this is their
best offer yet and it won't last long
with Helix better sleep starts
[Music]
now that that's funny and dark U but I'm
sure accurate uh you know I've talked to
any number of members you show up and um
there is this kind of helplessness that
they describe um that you know if you
had enough people get together maybe
they could change it so you have uh been
advocating for things outside of
Congress to around structural election
reforms uh you think that the primaries
are a problem you're concerned like I am
that they might have a contingent
election like they did in 1824 because
no one gets to 270 electoral votes I
will say that that that danger is uh
more prevalent this time for a number of
reasons um no labels is one possibility
another possibility is uh some kind of
confusion or dispute um you are going to
have RFK out there as and independent
that we know of and there might be
others um so what is your short list of
most urgent reforms uh that you think
might give us more of a fighting chance
and maybe even have the leaders of
congress come together and say hey guys
we we can do things differently well
yeah certainly you you you flaged you
flagged my two immediate concerns first
uh the House of
Representatives needs to clarify its
rules and procedures for handling a
contested election I mean they're really
basic questions like a certain number of
members from one state if they split
three to two in favor of one candidate
in favor of the other or the versus the
other does that you know vote get
counted or do they have to be unanimous
like there's really basic things about
proceedings that are just not in place
and that just opens up a terrible
terrible possibility of people following
really bad incentives like they did back
on on January 6th when again we had a
100 plus year old statute that was very
vague and was grossly out of date and so
you know it's like a game if the rules
are not clear people are going to
exploit them to the hilt so that is a
big thing second thing is I really do
believe
States um counties municipalities need
to continue experimenting with a whole
variety of systemic election reforms
whether it's rank Choice voting final
five nonpartisan
uh
redistricting approval
voting experiment and let's see if we
can get candidates who are better in
quality but also better incentivized in
terms of how they behave when they
campaign and how they govern and let's
take away those lessons and see if we
can keep you know improving this
Machinery of governance yeah I mean that
that's the forward parties tune for sure
so are you a multi-member district guy
too then I'm I am I'll I'll
confess I'm uh I'm I'm intrigued by it
Lee grutman's a friend of mine he's a
super smart guy I read just about
everything he writes um but I'm not
convinced yet uh not least because it
would only apply to the House of
Representatives not the Senate and
moreover you know multiart member kind
of multiparty parliamentary sort of
structures those usually are in
parliamentary systems where like
when your party wins you also get
positions in the ministry the executive
branch and that doesn't work in our
separation of power system so that kind
of concerns me I'm also you know another
thing I I've got is an open question and
I want to talk to Lee and other really
smart people about
this I'm not sure there's any other
government that has candidates funded
the way we fund candidates here in
America with all the dark money sling
around versus party money versus
individual money versus and that that
creates a
market and what happens in that market
do we end up getting a troll party where
they literally are committed and branded
on like trolling governance that would
actually do pretty you had the troll
party you would get a Solid 5 to 10% of
Americans to say it it's like that when
they named that boat stinky mix Sting
face or whatever that was so you been
inside you've been outside do you still
have friends who are uh like lifetime
tenur uh Nerds inside Congress and then
how do they look at you you guys have
lunch and be like hey like what's life
on the outside and and also um as you've
been campaigning for various changes uh
over this last number of years at
multiple think tanks um what level of
optimism do you have I mean certainly
the concern level keeps on Rising even
you might not have predicted this
uh you know historic ouer and uh fail
well maybe the the failed nomination
votes so any of us could have
predicted afterwards it's like hey guys
that guy was jinting up for the speaker
slot for years and years and he barely
got it so it's like you guys just trying
to pull it off uh you know immediately
it's going to be unlikely so yeah inside
versus outside and what what's your
level of optimism yeah I absolutely stay
in contact um I have the they are they
are friends
um they are super smart so I learn from
them when I listen to them um and also
they have information that I'm just not
privy to um and you know sometimes when
I write stuff on the outside you know
maybe I only get 90% correct maybe I get
only 80% correct maybe I didn't notice a
variable and these people can help clue
me in and make me smarter so uh
absolutely I stay connected with them
and you know as far as the op
optimism uh I guess I'm by Nature kind
of optimistic I'm a realist but I'm
optimistic uh I feel like
because there's this natural churn in
representative government I mean one of
the things we found for example in our
survey of of congressional staff is that
the average tenure is less than seven
years so and by the way that burnout
getting worse and worse from what I've
heard it's like the the me the people
there it used to be like hey if you have
a job on Capitol Hill then you are uh
doing the greatest job of all time and
it doesn't matter what you get paid
doesn't matter what your hours are
you're like a modified West Wing
character you're living the dream and
then now more and more people are like
and this sucks you know like wait we get
here the climate is nasty I don't get
anything done it used to be that you
might socialize with staffers and other
offices and now you don't CU all the
doors are closed cuz everyone's uh you
know a little bit uh anxious um so
people are burning out out more and more
yeah yeah that's one why a bunch of us
left right center have advocated and had
some success with um getting those
people paid more but also improving the
kind of working environment down there
you
know creating more of a career pathway
for going up clarification of roles you
know dealing with the sexual harassment
problem that's been on Capitol Hill
forever and like trying to improve it so
you can stop that turnover CU that's a
huge brain drain and all that flows the
private sector for the most part yeah
yeah I I I I can actually relate like I
have a a friend I went to school with uh
who wound up on Capitol Hill very
talented um ended up a chief of staff to
uh one Senator and then another Senator
and then became a lobbyist because he's
like okay like you know what what next
he was a very very talented guy um and
so he went to the private sector the way
you're describing by the way I remember
when he started he was like I'm never
going to become a lobbyist and then then
fast forward 15 years he became a
lobbyist and like I didn't blame him at
all because that's what the market was
for his uh his
experience yeah yeah it's the
legislative branch has frequently been
Pennywise and pound foolish and um you
know this gets us back this actually
ties back to the primaries
thing you would think that members of
Congress if you were really cynical
would be like every year voting to raise
their own pay and to hire more staff and
to just be if they
did but actually the opposite is true
and in part it's because GOP legislators
running through a primary want to be
able to brag that they did not raise
their own pay and that they're actually
not spending all the money that's
allotted to their office but they're
returning some of it to the treasury
which means that you know you're
understaffed your staff aren't being
paid as well as they should and guess
what they leave they're not going to
hang around people have lives to live
you know people want to have families
they want to own property and you know
you're getting paid $34,000 a year or
$41,000 a year in a junior staff
position like why are you going to hang
around for that especially with the work
environment wow it's that low it's even
lower than I thought I mean is that in
their home District because in DC they
probably have to make a little more just
to live or is it just that low it might
be that low yeah yeah it it is that low
I mean Chiefs Chief of Staff the people
at the top of the pecking order you know
they're in a lot they're in a lot better
spot but uh you know DC I've been here
20 years uh the cost of living here is
it's not quite New York City high but
boy it's it's
expensive imagine running for president
and wanting to share what you
experienced in a way that's entertaining
edifying and maybe even a little bit
scary that's the last election out in
bookstores now a novel about an
independent presidential candidate a
journalist with a massive story and what
the heck could be our next slast
election check it out at andrewyang.com
[Music]
yeah I'm going to go on the record and
say I think that congressional salary
should be higher for members I mean
174,000 sounds like a lot but if you
have to maintain a place in DC which you
probably do in a place in your home
District which you probably do uh it
it's not that much you know I mean um
that that's pre-tx so you know after you
pay taxes and the rest of it then pay
rent on two places uh is not that much
um I I actually think that kind of stuff
ends up encouraging corruption because
there are a lot of members that are
looking around being like wait a minute
why am I living in hand to mouth and
then you're surrounded by rich people
all the time and the rich people are
like o do I have an opportunity for you
you know like and then you're like oh I
should be friends with you um and so you
w up wind up with all all kind of
influence and Corruption that might not
be the case if you paid someone enough
where it's like look I actually don't
need stuff from you like you know I'm
getting paid I don't know what the
appropriate level would be I also think
we should pay people on the way out to
encourage them not to become lobbyists
like if they become lobbyists then you
don't get this money but if you if you
head to uh think tank or uh University
or nonprofit then we'll we'll pay you
this money uh just try to try and get
him out of the revolving door yeah but
no I I just circling back to your
question I am uh I I am optimistic I
mean 2014 when I was finishing up my
time at Congressional research service
nobody was talking about Congressional
capacity the phrase just didn't exist uh
on Capitol Hill and now it's the thing
people are talking about it and they're
moving forward bit by bit it's small
stuff they're not tackling the big
problems like how do we divide up the
works between committees and how do we
fix the budget law like that stuff's
going to be stuck for a while because
it's hard but smaller stuff you know
let's pay staff a little bit more okay
let's make Capitol Hill a little less
toxic workplace you know used to be the
case for example this is crazy used to
be the case that if you were a staffer
and you were sexually harassed by a
member of
Congress you had no in-house legal
resource to go to
to fight back but the member
did how could that be right but that's
the way it was for decades well guess
what that's changed so there's been
these small things that are moving
forward and the fact that we had the
select committee on demonetization of
Congress a group of people who were
devoted to working on this stuff was
great and now they're a subcommittee
like that's all they do is just work on
implementing this stuff and generating
new ideas and they're just churning
along in a bipartisan way that that
wasn't here 2014 and earlier um so this
is good now if we can just get the
Senate to do that maybe have some
conversations around the filibuster and
holds and the other sort of stuff that's
going on there and then get them both
together to work together on kind
of Congress wide stuff like the budget
law well maybe we could actually make a
real Improvement for I uh retire and
spend my golden years sitting in a road
booat with a fishing rod in my hand now
I you have the same spirit I do Kevin
which is like if things were going
better I'd go do something else and
nothing would make me
happier um so the closing note a lot of
what you've written about is news to
most people like most people don't
understand the inner workings of what's
going on in in Congress do you think
like here's my sense I think if people
understood just how dysfunctional was
they'd be they'd be pissed
off personally like if you if people
understand cuz like I have enough
friends in Congress where like I hear
stuff and I'm just like dude that sounds
terrible that sounds that sounds super
miserable even something as basic as
like what what's how you spend 50 to 60%
of your time ding for dollars that
sounds super miserable you know like
like why why you know like why are we
trying what like you know but as soon as
you get in the system you it's like well
this is the way I advance so do you have
a message for people who um who are on
the outside looking in about like you
know how Congress because even now like
the average American has caught on that
something is a
Miss from this last number like you know
of of uh days and weeks where where we
didn't have a speaker and a bunch of
other things um I I mean I the way I
would put it is that you have an
institution that doesn't have the
incentive to uh modernize itself to
re-energize itself and so people just
kind of trudge along and do things that
may or may not make sense uh it is that
like but it is possible that if just
enough of them got together they could
change things for the better is that a a
reasonable perspective on it yeah yeah
absolutely um to the average voter the a
you person out there listening I would
say here's
one small thing you could do that could
create the space for members of Congress
to up their game and to improve things
and that is to go to your senator
and members websites click the contact
button and write them a little note
asking them what are you doing to
improve the functioning of
Congress and what are you doing to work
across the aisle with members of the
other party to advance the public good
those those two little questions please
write back to me promptly thank you with
your name ask them put them on the spot
make them answer the question and if
they get enough of those coming in
they'll feel it members of Congress do
pay attention to emails and mails coming
in their staff absorbs that stuff and
relates it to the member it's worth
doing but very few people actually want
to do it it's easier just to complain
about Congress I get it well Kevin that
that's a very very fine directive and
I'm sure a lot of people listening uh
can do that uh if they want to keep up
with you your work your writings how can
they best do so well you can find me out
there uh on X the site formerly known as
Twitter under Kevin rosar uh you can
Google uh understanding Congress podcast
and you'll see that the podcast I have
is on a whole variety of formats and
follow me there and uh yeah those are
the two obvious ways um or you can just
drop me an email at kevin. Kosar ai.org
and say hi you have an entire podcast
called understanding Congress I
do because it's so hard to understand
well heck man um that that that's such
an awesome value ad uh thank you for
contributing that to the world oh my
pleasure thank
you